Burnie comes out on top Biden and Warren
collapse and Bloomberg lurks in the
shadows waiting to buy the Democratic
nomination but the biggest winner of all
in the New Hampshire presidential
primaries was Donald Trump don't take my
word for it we look past the top-line
numbers to the hidden lessons of last
night's vote then Jessie smollett's
attacker has finally brought to justice
about time and an injustice is corrected
in the sentencing of GOP operative Roger
stone for the unforgivable crime of
working for president Trump all that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show whoo boy do we have
a lot to get to out of New Hampshire
last night I feel we could do seven or
eight hours on New Hampshire but we
don't have that much time so we've got
to get to it before that I've got to
thank our friends over at ray con if you
have wires coming out of your earbuds in
2020 you are just ridiculous
what are you doing okay boomer we're
that's fine even nobody should have
those wireless those wires coming out of
their ear buds you know about rake on
ear buds they start about half the price
of any other premium wireless earbuds on
the market and they sound just as
amazing as all the other top audio
brands that you know the latest model
from Ray Con is their best one yet it
has six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass a more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit and it fits in
properly it's not just a one size fits
all kind of thing really an incredible
product ray con is for the pros I'm
telling you like just get them just go
get him okay now it's the time to get
the latest and greatest from Ray con get
15% off your order at buy rake on.com
slash Knowles canna wles
that's buy rake on Comm slash Knowles
for 15% off rake on wireless earbuds
stop what you are doing
once you finish listening to this
podcast and then go to buy rake on Comm
slash Knowles canna wles all right lots
of news out of New Hampshire last night
the
final count who knows if it's really the
final count they change these things all
the time
bernie is on top bernie sanders followed
by Pete Buda jej followed by Amy
Klobuchar who got a ton of momentum
coming out of Iowa and out of the last
debate followed by poor Elizabeth Warren
followed pathetically by Joe Biden who
is only slightly above Tom Steyer a guy
whose name you probably haven't heard of
and you might remember him from his
silly ties from the debates followed by
Elsie Gabbard who's currently suing
Hillary Clinton so not a good place for
Biden and that doesn't even tell the
whole story the obviously they all those
people got some votes but all we really
care about are the delegates because
determined by the number of votes you
get in the primary you then get a
certain number of Delegates and the
delegates are what you bring with you to
the convention to figure out who the
nominee is going to be by the delegate
count Bernie and Peabody judge probably
gonna get the same number of Delegates
looks like they both got nine delegates
and Amy Klobuchar is getting six
delegates and then Elizabeth Warren zero
delegates Biden zero delegates Steyr
tulsi zero delegates right so these
things can change as the final numbers
come in let's get to a deeper level of
analysis than that that's like the top
line analysis right on the top level
Bernie Sanders won and his supporters
are radicals and that is scary right
that's the top line
Bernie voters are on another level
Bernie campaign supporters are on
another level Bernie Sanders honeymooned
in the Soviet Union okay when it looked
like Bernie won his supporters all came
out in New Hampshire and they chanted
about how a whole nother world is
possible
[Applause]
we are unstoppable another world is
possible this is what leftist radicals
chant all the time they chanted at
Occupy Wall Street they chanted it at
all of the radical movements that we've
seen in recent years and that's a scary
thing because it's it's telling you that
they are these utopians these
revolutionaries these radicals another
world is not possible we're not going to
overturn human nature we're not going to
go back to the Garden of Eden we're not
going to have heaven on earth it's just
not going to happen and when people try
to pursue those goals through politics
usually that leads to widespread human
suffering so that's very scary also
scary is that Bernie's campaign
volunteers want to throw all of us into
gulags what we're gonna do with them
gulag wall first what are we gonna do
with those people that resist the change
that's a big deal I'll tell you what
in Cuba what do they do to reactionaries
they shot them on the beach
[Music]
if you want to fight against a
revolution you're gonna die there it is
that's a guy who works for the Bernie
Sanders campaign and apparently still
works for the Bernie Sanders campaign
James O'Keefe released that video of the
guy saying yeah they're getting the
Gulag they're getting the wall and
apparently he's still still works for
them so that's pretty scary that a
campaign of that kind of radicalism one
okay the good news is that this probably
finished off the other radical who is in
the race which is Elizabeth Warren Liz
Warren needed to do well in New
Hampshire Liz Warren is from
Massachusetts Massachusetts candidates
need to do well in New Hampshire right
over there their neighbor in the
Northeast and she didn't she did really
badly in New Hampshire she bombed in
Iowa she bombed in New Hampshire it's
not looking good in upcoming states at
this point probably Liz Warren is
running a zombie campaign and Trump took
the opportunity to spike the football
I loved it of all the tweets he sent out
yesterday he sent out a lot of really
funny tweets this is my favorite one
quote Elizabeth Warren sometimes
referred to as Pocahontas is having a
really bad night I think she is sending
signals that she wants out calling for
unity is her way of getting there going
home and having a nice cold beer with
her husband is referring to that really
cringe-inducing social media video where
liz warren pretended to be a regular old
gal and she had what i assume was her
first sip of beer ever
and then she very awkwardly hugged her
husband and said thank you for being
here in their own home everything about
it was very very bizarre and of course
trump is just absolutely rubbing salt
into that wound is saying elizabeth is
sometimes referred to as Pocahontas
mostly by him and he's got these little
puns in here she's sending signals like
she's sending smoke signals and it's
just a really really funny way of
enjoying the last days of her campaign
the other good news for people who are
worried about the socialist ascendancy
in America here who are looking at the
the rise of Bernie and 2016 and now and
2020 in these states and saying oh my
gosh this one of the two major political
parties in the u.s. is actually
embracing socialism this is so scary
young people are embracing socialism how
did we get to this point the other good
news is that the fake moderate he's not
really a moderate but at least he's
running right now as a moderate Budaj
basically tied Bernie Sanders he ones
slightly fewer votes probably one the
same number of Delegates this happened
in Iowa and Iowa Bernie Sanders got more
votes than people to judge and yet
Peabody Judge got more delegates that's
just the way the nominating process
works the other good news about that
that you've now got this radical and
this fake moderate who are pretty much
tied the good news about that is that
fake moderate Peabody judge has a zero
percent chance of beating Donald Trump
in November zero percent not not 10% not
5% 0% chance Pete Budaj edge is a small
town mayor he has zero accomplishments
he's never done anything he has
crucially a bad reputation on racial
issues which will kill you in any party
but certainly in the identity politics
of obsessed democratic party today
having any whiff of a bad reputation on
race politics not very good and this is
the politically incorrect thing to say
his sexual preferences are going to hurt
him if not make him unelectable as a
Democrat in 2020 you're not supposed to
point that out and yet it's true don't
take my word for it even the New York
Times is admitting that we'll get to
that in a second first I got to thank
our friends over at ancestry it's very
cool to understand your ancestry I've
always been really interested in this my
grandfather when he retired did a lot of
genealogical research I found out on my
father's side I've got four ancestors on
the Mayflower found out these very cool
stories about them like for instance one
of them was a pilgrim and the rest were
pretty much complete degenerates
you can learn those kind of stories
through ancestry building out your
family tree and now with ancestry DNA
you can reveal your ethnic origins you
can get historical details that bring
unique family stories to life
ancestry DNA doesn't just tell you which
countries your family's from
it also pinpoints the specific regions
within them gives you insight into
geographical detail about your history
you can trace the paths of your recent
ancestors figure out how and why they
left where they left it no other DNA
testing service delivers any anything
like this unique interactive experience
get started today
take your genealogical history buff
interest to the next level go to
ancestry.com slash Knowles Canada wles
and get your ancestry DNA kit to start
your free trial that's ancestry.com
slash Knowles ancestry.com slash Knowles
ok it's politically incorrect to say
this you're not allowed to say it except
even the New York Times admits it Pete
Budaj edges sexual preferences are going
to hurt him specifically within the
Democratic Party now that seems odd
doesn't it because the Democratic Party
seems so progressive on sexual questions
yes and know what the New York Times
pointed out in October is quote as Pete
Buddha judge courts black voters his
sexuality is a hurdle for some because
historically specifically among black
voters sexual revolutionary politics you
know kind of the sexual liberation
movement of the 1960's which includes
homosexuality is not particularly
popular the Buddha judge campaign
acknowledged this to circulated a memo
saying that homosexuality was going to
hurt him in South Carolina
the reason it's gonna hurt him in South
Carolina is because that's really the
first state where any of these
candidates have to win over black voters
it's why Joe Biden is trying to hang on
to his campaign until South Carolina is
because he's the only candidate who does
well with black voters regardless of
your feelings on this matter that is
what it means politically and so he's
got a number of flaws I mean not only if
he had a huge name if he had a huge list
of accomplishments maybe that would be
able to to overcome some of those other
other political flaws but right now
probably not the case so for the
candidates who still have a pulse the
leading moderate candidate has
fundamental political flaws Budaj edge
is such a weak moderate for
runner that amy klobuchar in new
hampshire jumped to third place simply
by not being completely insane which is
high praise in the 2020 Democratic
primary simply by saying on the debate
stage that maybe we shouldn't kill all
the babies simply by saying on the
debate stage maybe maybe the Democratic
nominee shouldn't be an open avowed
socialist simply by doing that she
jumped from nothing to third place Amy
Klobuchar if you just look at her and
listen to her is a terrible retail
candidate she's awkward on the campaign
trail she's stiff she repeats the same
awkward jokes she's not a good candidate
okay somebody like a Barack Obama or a
Ronald Reagan these really great
campaigners she is not and yet she's
jumping up that moderate Lane the reason
she's spiking up is because Budaj edge
just doesn't have it so who's gonna stop
Bernie the only person left in the New
Hampshire field who can stop Bernie is
Joe Biden but the Biden campaign
collapsed last night the Biden campaign
came in fifth
humiliating he didn't need to win New
Hampshire but he needed a second earth
at least a third-place finish and he
came in fifth absolutely pathetic his
campaign is trying to spin it probably
right now it's over here's Joe Biden
trying to protest trying to explain why
his absolutely empty campaign is still
going to hobble along we just heard from
the first two of 50 states to him not
all the nation not half the nation not a
quarter of the nation not 10% to to all
right come from that's the opening bell
not the closing bell
so in here all these pundits and experts
cable TV talkers talked about the race
tell them it ain't over man we're just
getting started
[Applause]
it ain't over man who you trying to
convince Joe Biden this is the tell-tale
sign of a weak campaign is when they go
out there and say hey look we just heard
from two random states okay look just
two random states yo you mean the two
perhaps the two most important states to
determining who the party nominee is
gonna be Iowa New Hampshire I mean not
the only two important states to
determine that but two very important
ones so the radical is winning and the
moderates are too weak to stop him and
the only guy out here who might win the
general election got clobbered the
hardest this is just terrible news for
the Democratic Party but it's great news
for the secret moderate who all the
Democratic elites are rallying behind
now and that is Mike Bloomberg Mike
Bloomberg wasn't on the ballot in New
Hampshire he got into the race too late
to do that he's not only thing he's
gonna be on the ballot in Nevada or
South Carolina the first four states the
really important ones he's not even
going to be there but Mike Bloomberg has
infinite money he has all of the money
he's already spent three or four hundred
million dollars getting into this race
that's why his numbers have shot through
the roof he already spent money buying
off the DNC he made max contributions to
the Democratic National Committee right
before he got in that's why they changed
the debate rules to let him into the
next debate this guy is now laying low
and waiting and because of the flaws of
every single moderate so-called moderate
candidate in the race Budaj Biden Club
you char because of that he has a chance
to enter the race late but Mike
Bloomberg can't beat Trump you can't do
it if given the choice between two New
York building billionaires you got one
New York billionaire who is a soda
stealing gun grabbing Chardonnay sipping
cigarettes topping nanny-state scold and
a successful funny TV host we gonna pick
who or Americans gonna want to see for
the next season of the White House it's
probably gonna be President Trump the
other reason it's actually two more
reasons why Trump beats Bloomberg the
two reasons are one
Bloomberg will be viewed by the
progressive base as having stolen the
election regardless of what really
happens
you saw the progressives get their
election stolen in 2016 through Bernie
Sanders you're seeing it happen again
now in Iowa and New Hampshire so they're
gonna see Bloomberg is this guy
parachuting in stealing the election
from him the second reason that
Bloomberg doesn't beat Trump is that
Bloomberg cannot convincingly make the
case that Trump is scary we're dangerous
and I'll show you how Trump actually he
sent out a tweet where he gave Mike
Bloomberg his new mean nickname called
mini Mike and that's what everyone's
focusing on they're not focusing on the
second part of the tweet which is a
photo of Trump and Bloomberg on the golf
course and that's actually the whole
whole tweet really we'll get to that in
a second first I've got to thank our
friends over at LifeLock every two
seconds there is a victim of identity
theft every two seconds
fortunately LifeLock uses proprietary
technology to detect and alert you to a
wide range of potential identity threats
like your social security number for
sale on the dark web and if there's an
identity issue one of life locs identity
restoration specialists will fix it now
of course no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions and all businesses of
course but with life lock you get
identity theft protection to help
protect your devices against cyber
threats for up to 25 percent off your
first year it's really important I know
what you're thinking especially if
you've been using the internet for a
long time you're saying nobody wants my
identity nobody's trying to steal my
information nobody even knows my
information it's not out there
it is you can get it people can find it
and when you get your identity stolen it
is a disaster just protect yourself now
go to LifeLock comm slash nulls canna
wles that's LifeLock comm slash Knolls
KO wles
for 25% off all right the other reason
it's this twofold reason why Bloomberg
doesn't beat Trump and you need both of
them at the same time one is Bloomberg
is just going to be be viewed so
suspiciously as having stolen it from
the progressives but two he can't make
the case that
Trump is scary Trump sends out this
tweet says quote mini mike is a short
ball very hitter
I love the syntax the grammar doesn't
doesn't seem grammatical but it does
work in a tweet he's a short ball hitter
meaning when he golfs but he's also
saying he's short very short tiny club
head speed Keep America great so the
tweet is just unsubtle e calling Mike
Bloomberg short and Mike Lou Berg is
very short I've been in rooms and at
events with Mike Bloomberg they're
saying on the internet that he's 5/8 or
510 or something not even close not even
close
like he's a he's a petite man much
smaller than people even realize right
now so that's the tweet right tweet is
that he's short the genius of this tweet
is not calling him short President Trump
does this he makes fun of people and
their physical attributes and it works
it's distasteful we don't like it but it
totally totally works okay and maybe
that's just where we are in 2020 that's
not the genius though giving him a
nickname okay he was obviously going to
do that the genius of the tweet is
showing that Mike Bloomberg and
president Trump have golfed together I
think on multiple occasions the genius
of the tweet is showing that Mike
Bloomberg doesn't really think Trump is
scary Mike Bloomberg was piling around
with Trump just a little while ago it's
actually one of the reasons that Hillary
Clinton couldn't really make the case
that Trump is so scary is because
Hillary Clinton went to his wedding
right it's that they were they kind of
piled around she asked him for donations
it's just it totally blunted the attack
that Trump is Hitler Trump is a Nazi
Trump as a fascist right well if he's a
fascist why you playing golf with him
why are you going to his wedding - one
of the real advantages to having this
celebrity guy this pop-culture figure in
running for your nomination is everyone
knows that we we all know him the voters
and even the people who are running
against him have piled around with him
before so I think it's a really smart
way to keep getting that in there it's
like a look I know these people all
right they're all biessing you right now
that I'm such a scary guy so that pretty
much damages
all of the candidates who were in New
Hampshire and even a candidate wasn't in
New Hampshire who won Bernie did fine
but he effectively tied with Buddha
judge Buddha judge Warren and Klobuchar
can't win a general election Joe Biden
can't win the primary Bloomberg I
strongly suspect cannot rally that
progressive Bernie base around him or
beat Trump so it looks pretty good looks
like president Trump did very well in
New Hampshire you but you don't need to
take my word for obviously look I think
the president's doing a good job I
support him so I want to make sure that
I'm not just looking at this through the
lens of my preferences or wishful
thinking but you can look at the exit
polls and it all seems to back this up
okay the numbers from the exit polling
showed that turnout was down from 2016
like in some cases significantly down
but Trump won in 2016 so if - the way
that Democrats win this time is for turn
out to be way up and enthusiasm to be
way up and all those people who stayed
home in 2016 because they hated Hillary
Clinton they're going to turn out to the
polls this time right because they hate
Trump so much except that's not what
we're seeing if this is a referendum on
Donald Trump Donald Trump's going to win
the Democrats are less excited this time
than they were last time according to
the exit polls that that ends the
election is that if that keeps up even
worse for Democrats even worse turnout
is especially down among young voters so
one of the arguments you hear from
people who say that Trump isn't going to
get reelected or they're Democrats they
don't like Trump they'll say look the
reason Trump's gonna lose this time is
because all the young people are going
to turnout there's going to be so many
more young voters this year just in
terms of voter eligibility and
enthusiasm to go vote that Trump's going
to get clobbered well that doesn't seem
to be what's borne out by the exit polls
but the exit polls are showing is not
only are there not more young voters
this time there are fewer they're
actually less interested in this
election than they were last time in in
2016 young voters made up 19 percent of
the New Hampshire Democratic primary
vote that's down to 11% this year it's a
major cut it's a major reduction adding
to that
you've got some polls showing President
Trump making inroads with black and
Hispanic voters and it's not just one or
two polls it's three polls four polls
showing big inroads with with black
voters especially who knows what those
polls are right or not but if he makes
any inroads with them then the
Democratic Party is in a bad place the
Democratic Party needs to have a lock
especially in the black vote but they
need to do very very well with Hispanics
as well in order to win and it looks
like all the numbers are going the other
direction so what are the takeaways from
New Hampshire weak front-runner and
division among the moderate wing
moderate wing lower voter enthusiasm
lower youth enthusiasm and a possible
loss of critical minority support those
are all bad headlines for Democrats
coming out of New Hampshire all great
headlines for Trump and Republicans
MSNBC accidentally showed some evidence
of this that 2020 might not be going the
way they wanted they accidentally showed
it when they were in New Hampshire
they're trying to interview all these
Democratic primary voters so they
actually forgot that there was a
Republican primary you forget it because
the incumbent is gonna win the primary
but they're out there talking to say oh
hey which of these fun candidates Bernie
or Klobuchar who which one did you vote
for sir and they didn't like his answer
we have a voter out here sir you're
getting you were watching so you're
gonna be on television now can you tell
us John Trump you voted for Donald John
Trump yeah look at that Bernie Sanders
is not appealing to you the whole
ideology ideology would be destructive
to the country it's anti growth it's
anti family it's anti-american and as a
Roman Catholic it's anti life anti life
oh man that guy totally nailed them and
I love the look on her face you voted
for Trump what excuse me what was that
this opens up the second side of New
Hampshire which nobody is talking about
which is there was a New Hampshire
Republican primary we all know who was
going to
win that one I mean it's sort of like
the election of Saddam Hussein the
question is is he gonna get 99 percent
of the vote or you know 89 percent of
the movies still gonna win by a
landslide the Republican side actually
shows us something because it shows
historic popularity I truly historic
popularity we'll get to that in a second
first got to thank our friends over at
honey you know how much I love honey
honey is the free online shopping tool
that automatically finds the best promo
codes and applies them to your shopping
cart and you know how wonderful it feels
to save but the question is how does it
feel to save with honey saving with
honey it feels like just like when
you're about to jump on the subway and
you're getting just before the doors
close it feels like hitting every single
green light on your commute it feels
like finishing up your favorite episode
of this very podcast just as you're
about to walk in the door to work it's
just it feels so good because what honey
does I've been using honey since before
the daily wiring existed it gives you
the best prices anywhere you don't need
to search it you don't need to find
those coupon codes it just gets it to
you tells you how the prices have been
changing it's an amazing it's an amazing
browser extension honey supports over
30,000 of stores online stores like
Macy's Target Sephora Best Buy way more
just go do it right now honey honey is
an amazing a browser extension think of
it as a little daily victory and it's
free it installs in just a few seconds
get it for free at join honeycomb slash
Knowles that is join honey calm slash
Knowles Canada beaut le s the Republican
victory here is not being covered in the
news because there's really only one
candidate but it's big
you know Trump technically had primary
candidates in the Republican Party it's
just nobody remembers them because they
never had a shot on the Republican side
of the New Hampshire primary Donald
Trump outperformed all of his success
predecessors all of them in terms of
numbers that performed his predecessors
in terms of the share of the vote last
night when there were about 54 percent
of precincts reporting so just over half
of the votes were in President Trump had
already received more
raw of votes then Barack Obama George
Bush and Ronald Reagan in their
re-election campaigns in New Hampshire
half the vote was in and he had gotten
more votes now Bill Clinton had also
done pretty well in his re-election
campaign but by the time 62% of the vote
was in Trump beat Bill Clinton in terms
of raw votes he likely beat the voting
percentages of the last three incumbent
presidents who won re-election that is a
big number
it shows enthusiasm right you had a
night where democratic enthusiasm was
down key constituencies among the
Democrats enthusiasm were down and
enthusiasm to go to a poll that you
don't need to go to right the president
is the incumbent he's gonna win the
primary enthusiasm to go to even that
primary poll way up I mean you see it at
these rallies you look at a Joe Biden
rally he's got like five people at it
and half of them are asleep you look at
a trump rally it's stadiums full of
people and I know that that's not data
right those are just anecdotes because
it's one event here one event there one
event there but you just look at the
enthusiasm maybe you can't measure that
but you can see it it's real that's what
we saw last night in New Hampshire so it
was a big night for Bernie in that it
showed that there was this committed
progressive base he did win the state
but the the division among the Democrats
and then Davitt further division among
the moderates and then the total
suppression of enthusiasm compared with
Trump gives the state I think gives the
night to president Trump there's a
really sad moment - last night Andrew
yang dropped out of the race and another
one bites the dust another candidate
dropped out - actually Senator Michael
Bennet who none of you knew was even
running so that doesn't matter but
Andrew yang dropped out he was a kind of
interesting candidate at least on
Twitter at least he made people
interested on the Internet some
conservatives are lamenting the end of
his campaign I am NOT I think he
proposed one of the worst most
destructive most degrading ideas that
any candidate has floated in the entire
race that would
$1,000 a month the universal basic
income we'll get to why that is a
horrible horrible idea first we got to
go and say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube I told you about my friend Bill
whittles podcast cold-war what we saw
it's now number five on Apple podcasts
go to daily wire.com slash cold-war to
check that one out I know what you're
thinking you're thinking 2020 is already
almost over right we're actually just
getting started the election season is
just heating up and we want to help you
out so because we want to help you out
you get to use the promo code DW 2020
that will give you all that you need to
save 20% off of a daily wire membership
you know what you get you get so much
you get me you get the Ben Shapiro show
you at the end of clayvin show you get
them at wal show you get so much yet our
articles ad free you had access to live
broadcasts you get at the all access
tier you get into live online Q&A
discussions with all of us here at the
daily wire and our writers and our
special guests you ask we answer and the
tumbler fills right on up download The
Daily wire app a member exclusive and
you can get push notifications straight
to your phone you don't want to miss out
on this promo code DW twenty twenty
twenty percent off joined today and get
all the information you need for twenty
twenty daily wire.com we'll be right
back
andrew yang dropped out the yang gang is
over we knew it would happen
he was inevitable he was a sort of
amusing candidate but I I wanted to take
a moment to stomp on the grave of the
yang campaign because I think some
conservatives are taking their amusement
with the yang campaign too far or their
their pleasure that he's a sort of nice
nice seeming guy too far he might be a
nice guy I don't I don't know Andrew
yang I don't particularly care if he's a
nice guy
what he was proposing as a candidate was
one of the worst ideas that any
candidate was floating in the race his
idea the only actual idea that his
campaign had was to buy votes it was to
pay people $1,000 a month
pay everybody a thousand dollars a month
by their vote and that's it it's so
insidious it's such a wicked
anti-american anti human and degrading
idea that I just want to stomp it out
it's called the universal basic income
there are different versions of this he
called his the freedom dividend the idea
being we're a really rich country so
let's take money from some people and
give everyone $1,000 a month now the
good version or the better version of
this proposal is that you're going to
eliminate the entire welfare state all
the entitlement programs are gone and
then you're gonna pay people $1,000 a
month and then that'll be really good
you'll save money people get to choose
how to spend their money and everybody
wins right know everybody doesn't win
everybody loses first of all the numbers
don't work you can't actually eliminate
the welfare state and offset that by
paying people $1,000 a month even if you
could it's politically impossible is the
whole point of the welfare state is that
we're not going to have people dying in
the streets in a civilized country so
you give everybody $1,000 a month
we know that the poor will always be
with us we know that people will always
make irresponsible decisions with their
money at least some portion of people
and so some people are gonna blow
through that thousand dollars a month
then what they're gonna need more
assistance are we gonna tell them tough
luck too bad live on the street hope you
do well no nobody's gonna do that only
in the wildest fever dreams of
libertarian teenagers does anybody
actually say sorry Buster you're out of
luck so what you would really get is you
pay
a thousand dollars a month and you still
have the welfare and entitlement state
politically it's impossible to change
that even if you could it would still be
a wicked evil degrading destructive
system because you are then making
welfare dependence out of every single
American you are getting every single
American hooked on the government dole
you are degrading them you are making
those people unable to stand on their
own two feet you're you're its it be
like getting them hooked on a drug
you're just slowly getting them hooked
on that drug and the government as
Ronald Reagan said very rightly the
government that is big enough to give
you everything you want is big enough to
take away everything you have when the
government is giving you a lot of money
that's not just an a gift outright
that's not just a wonderful grace or
manna from heaven that is a means of
political control because once you get
comfortable with that 12 grand a year
then you're not going to want to lose it
when the government starts making
demands of you in exchange for that 12
grand a year you're gonna have to do
them a horrible idea
I hope it's an idea that is dead I hope
it never comes back and I'm very glad
that the Andrew yang campaign is over
even though I will miss the memes the
memes were very funny when Andrew yang
dropped out he made a very nice
statement doesn't cover up for this
terrible idea he had Michael Bennett
also dropped out but nobody knows so
that's fine there's some good news
before we go I have to talk about some
good news for our criminal justice
system moving away from 2020 politics
into the nuts and bolts of law and order
finally after months and months of
investigations of great crack police
work
we have caught Jesse smih let's attacker
we caught him
Jesse SMO let's attacker is being
brought to justice and of course Jesse
SMO let's attacker is Jesse Smollett
Jesse Smollett is that actor from that
show who pretended to get attacked in
Chicago in the middle of the night by
two Magha hat-wearing
Trump supporters while he was holding
his
Subway sandwich and the Trump supporters
came up behind him and beat him up and
put a noose around his neck and said
this is mega country because nothing
says mega country like the southside of
Chicago and nothing about this made any
sense for some reason he still had the
noose around his neck when the cops got
there later and for some reason he was
holding his somebody sandwich the entire
time so smollett oh then it turned out
that it was actually smell let's friends
and trainers who he had paid off to
stage the attack and it turned out that
they were Nigerian Menace probably not
white supremacists trouble would this
whole case is it just got swept under
the rug it looked like there were
political favors called in Jesse
Smollett was a favorite of certain
prominent Democratic politicians and it
was just gonna go away
luckily a special Cook County grand jury
handed down a new indictment on Tuesday
this was after a six-month investigation
by special prosecutor Dan Webb the
special prosecutor said in a statement
that Smollett had filed for false police
reports claiming that he was the victim
of a hate crime and that's that is
certainly what happened quote the grand
jury's investigation revealed that
Smollett planned and participated in a
staged hate crime attack and thereafter
made numerous false statements to
Chicago Police Department officers on
multiple occasions reporting a heinous
hate crime that he in fact knew had not
occurred I'm very glad he's being
brought to justice it's very important
you know in any criminal justice system
you need to have justice we don't think
about that anymore
we think that the whole purpose of the
criminal justice system is to
rehabilitate people it's like therapy
basically it's just another form of
therapy that involves handcuffs where we
think that that the secondary purpose of
the criminal justice system is to deter
crime also a worthwhile goal but the
primary purpose is justice justice
involves some punishment not excessive
punishment I don't want to lock away
Jesse Smollett and throw away the key I
don't think he should get capital
punishment right that would be so
excessive that wouldn't be justice but
likewise he should not get off the hook
justice is the key and we forget this in
the Federalist Papers you know I'm gonna
be covering the Federalist Papers
on the book club show you know the show
that I have at Prager you that's
be coming up in a little bit I was just
rereading them and the Federalist Papers
the people who designed our Constitution
made it very clear that the end of
government is justice it's not
unfettered individual liberty it's not
equality it's not redistributing
everybody's property it's justice so
what is justice well it's giving to
everybody what they deserve it's a it's
a tricky balance in this case justice
had been too lenient okay we but that's
but that was why it was an injustice and
now luckily we're coming back to
something this is more reasonable
there's another case in our criminal
justice system that was in the other
direction Roger stone a longtime GOP
operative he's kind of fashioned to this
image for himself as a dirty trickster
that's kind of his media personality but
he's GOP political consultant he's
worked on his iliyan campaigns he he
worked at for Richard Nixon he worked
for Ronald Reagan worked for a lot of
other candidates Roger stone longtime
advisor to Donald Trump longtime friend
of Donald Trump so when Donald Trump
runs for president stone is involved in
the early stages although Trump ended up
firing stone early on he felt that stone
was just trying to get attention and he
was more of a media figure than a real
political operative at the national
level that was the statement Trump gave
so he fired him because stone has this
reputation this this public persona and
because he had committed the
unforgivable crime of working for Donald
Trump at any point Roger stone gets
brought in by the Muller investigation
that hoax that sham that found nothing
and he gets charged for lying to
Congress for making false statements not
charged with selling the country to
Russia not charged with treason not
charged with bribery not charged with
really serious crimes charged with lying
to Congress and witness tampering and
obstruction of a proceeding so look
these are real offenses but they're not
high crimes and misdemeanors right so
the prosecutors who were going after
Roger
Stone who maybe had some political views
of their own that were opposed to Roger
stone they wanted to sentence this 70
year old man to nine years in prison
because he worked for Trump then he got
caught up in this bogus hoax criminal
investigation I mean I'm when I say
criminal investigation I mean it was a
crime that the damn investigation
happened in the first place
this Muller investigation is Russia hoax
he gets caught up in that because he
works for Trump and then he makes false
statements during that investigation and
then they want to throw him in jail for
nine years which is effectively the rest
of his life right when you're 70 years
old and you go to prison for nine years
that's it
not a whole lot after that because
because they don't like him I mean
that's really what this was about so
that's what the prosecutors wanted to do
the DOJ intervened they said this is
ridiculous what are you talking about
nine years in prison no way so they said
you've got to reduce that sentencing
what you're asking for and for
prosecutors quit and that and it's being
portrayed in the mainstream media's that
these prosecutors the great defenders of
law and order those prosecutors good I'm
glad they quit could you if any other
prosecutors agree with them they should
quit too
because that that would would have been
a miscarriage of justice to throw Roger
stone in the clink for nine years for
the rest of his life you're effectively
sentencing him to life in prison because
of your bureaucratic hoax investigation
that got him caught up in it and he made
false statements I'm not saying Rogers
don't you get off the hook completely
all right he did commit some offenses
here he did make these false statements
so the only way he should get off the
hook completely is if he gets a
presidential pardon I'm not saying the
prosecutor should totally drop
everything but nine years is excessive
justice requires some balance justice
requires understanding what people
really deserve not being too harsh and
excessive but not being too lenient
either also in the Federalist I was
reading one of the great lines of the
whole Federalist Papers you know the key
document to understanding our
Constitution in it the author writes mmm
nothing can be mum paraphrasing but
roughly says enough
and can be more foolish then founding
our politics on arithmetic 'el
principles meaning you can't just have a
completely hard and fast scientific rule
when we're talking about politics and
government you need to it just requires
too much understanding for that kind of
rigid ideological precision and in this
case if you stick to some rigid the max
sentence you can get for the guy it's
just as clearly unjust and the DOJ
recognize that I think the whole Trump
administration has has kind of been
realizing that and I think it's terrific
harsher sentence force Mallette a
lighter sentence for Roger stone make
sure justice is served in both but make
sure it's justice and not just political
revenge before we get out of here I've
got to I've got to drive the point home
about New Hampshire because I know I I
just want to make sure that I'm not
overstating the case here that it was
such a bad night for Democrats but I
realized I'm not not just because of the
exit polling not just because of that
Trump voter that MSNBC accidentally
found not just because of the relative
voter enthusiasm but also on MSNBC Chris
Matthews he came out and he said what
what I think a lot of Democrats are
thinking which is if this is how it all
keeps up Democrats are not gonna win in
2020 their regular center-left Democrats
who are not angry about the rich they
just want to be secure in their own
economy and their own lives and see
their kids once in a while if that's the
case Trump is gonna be tough to beat so
I don't know I think in either case I
think it's gonna be tough to beat Trump
I don't know where the Democratic Party
is ideologically shifted as part of the
progressive side as Bernie believes I
think it will and I think that's the big
question you heard it from Chris
Matthews you heard it from New Hampshire
voters and you heard it here first
be sure to come back tomorrow I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa alvera
production assistants McKenna Waters and
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
you